as you said I'm Ross skip and Brock
we're going to talk about finding lane
lines for self-driving cars so a little
bit about me despite my German sounding
last name I'm from the United States I
grew up in the middle of the country it
just happens to be host to one of the
largest motorsports events the
Indianapolis 500 so from an early age I
got interested in motorsports and went
to college for mechanical engineering
got involved in Motorsports there worked
in NASCAR for four years doing
simulation software development and on
many other things I traveled to the
racetracks with the team and did a race
strategy so I met the guys from Y hat
when I was working in NASCAR and decided
to go up to New York and work for them
and we were just recently acquired by
ultrix so talking about self-driving
cars there's a lot of news these days
about this company suing this company
over self-driving car technology or this
company teaming up with this other one
there's a lot of new jobs in the space
so it's a really hot topic but today I
just kind of want to show you that it's
it's not as scary as it seems to do a
simple task that they the big guys do so
at the core autonomous cars they need to
carry out three tasks they need to
perceive the world they need to make a
decision based on these perceptions and
then ultimately carry out some action so
for perception these cars are equipped
with many sensors one of them being a
lidar unit on the top of the car that's
kind of a big ball you'll see when one
of them drives by you so that's a laser
range-finding system it's going to be
scanning 360 degrees around the vehicle
and measuring distances to objects
and then for closer in detection there
is radar sensors to measure distances to
objects around them and then also
they're going to have cameras all around
the car we're going to be looking at the
forward-facing camera today and
analyzing those images so that's the
perception piece which feeds a number of
algorithms to make decisions and here's
a few samples from the Google
self-driving car making decisions about
stopping at a red light maintaining that
stop position while the light remains
red that upper picture is it's deciding
to make a lane change when there's an
obstruction and then this lower one it's
actually switching lanes when there's a
cyclists in the right lane so making
decisions about where is safe to drive
and if we need to come to a stop so the
final piece is carrying out some action
this is actually steering the steering
the car or stopping the car applying
more or less throttle so here here's an
example of the Tesla autopilot system
coming to a stop when there's a accident
in front of it this top one is the
Google car stopping when it looks like
there's a wheelchair and possibly
chasing some dog but I think they're
pretty excited that their car came to a
stop there even though that's that's not
data that they had trained with so
finding lane lines is part perception
we're going to be using that
forward-facing camera and then we're
going to make a decision about where
those lane lines are and where it's safe
to drive so here's an example of the
kind of thing we're going to be building
it's it's just processing the video as a
series of images we're going to produce
this nice green area that's safe safe
space to drive in
so in order to carry this out there's
there's going to be five main steps
we'll walk through the first is to
undistorted jizz the raw camera images
or have a little bit of distortion so
we'll carry that out we're going to warp
the image so we have a bird's-eye view
perspective looking down on the road
we'll isolate the lane line pixels from
the surrounding image we're going to fit
a curve through those pixels and then
take all that information overlay it
with that original image and we'll get
that nice video so the first step
removing distortion so camera lenses
cameras use lenses that distort the
image you can fit more more of the
surroundings into a smaller frame so
this is the typical type of distortion
that you'll see with these cameras it's
called barrel distortion where it looks
like those straight lines are boat on
the outside of the image so if we were
to take this image and do that
transformation warping to get a
bird's-eye view the the lines that
should be straight would have kind of a
bow to them so we need to do some
distortion Corrections
luckily OpenCV has a number of functions
that'll help us do this if you take some
pictures of chess boards at various
various perspectives and they suggest at
least ten photos I use twenty-two to
calibrate this camera but you just take
a series of these chessboard images and
then let OpenCV find those corners in
the image using this fine chessboard
corners function if you if this returns
that it's found those points you add
them to a list of these corner points
and then pass it into the calibrate
camera function which just takes those
image points that you found on the chess
boards and it's going to return a set of
distortion coefficient
which will transform the image based on
like a series of different distortions
and then also there's a camera matrix so
there's some linear algebra behind the
scenes I'd suggest looking at the opencv
documentation if you really want to get
to know know and love those functions
they do a really good job of explaining
kind of what's going on under the hood
but now that we have our camera
calibrated we can use another function
called undistorted image those two
matrices that we found previously and
you apply it and it will return this
undistorted image so you can see that
the those outside lines that were kind
of bowed are now pretty straight so we
should be able to get that bird's-eye
view we were talking about so we really
want this for fitting fitting curves and
finding lane lines it's going to be
easier to find those lines if we can
look down on the subject instead of
looking out on it so to do that we we
have to have a set of source points from
the original image so those are kind of
those are going to look like lanes going
off to infinity and we want to take
those points and warp them into straight
lines so this is just a straight road so
those lines should end up straight when
we do the the actual image warping and
to do that we call this get perspective
transform function which returns another
matrix more linear algebra who knows
what's going on but then you take the
output of that that matrix apply this
Worr perspective to that original image
with that matrix and it's going to
return this warped perspective so as you
get towards the top of the image you
notice that it gets a little more
pixelated obviously we can't create
resolution that didn't exist in the
original image but
there should be enough fidelity there to
isolate those pixels from the
surrounding image so how do we go about
doing that there's going to be two
approaches that we'll take one is color
selection and the other one's going to
be edge detection so for color selection
we're going to first kind of look at
what an image is inside of a computer so
taking a look at the first ten pixels of
an image just zooming in on that you can
see that it's just a series of these
little squares in each one of these
squares if we look at the value that
prints out is a set of three values in a
list so these these do mean something
one of them is a red value green value
and a blue value and these go from 0 to
255 in most images just because they're
8-bit images 2 to the 8th is 256 so 0 to
255 if all these are 255 it's going to
output white if they're all 0 it's going
to be black and then for each channel
the full value would so if it's 255 0 0
that will be all red and if anyone's
messed around with one of these sliders
that's really what you're doing
so looking at the first 2 by 2 pixels on
this image you can see that it's really
just a set of columns and rows so
knowing that it's going to be a little
bit easier to understand that we can
isolate different color channels within
this so there are more color spaces than
red green blue and some of these might
help us to isolate those Lane line
pixels from the surrounding image a
couple others are these hue/saturation
light and value color spaces so those
they just take RGB colors and then
them into this other representation of
that same image and then there's a
number of other ones there's this one is
called lab it uses lightness and then
there's two axes for the color and these
these are going to prove pretty helpful
so luckily OpenCV makes it really easy
to convert between these you just use
this convert color function pass in an
RGB color or or any other color as long
as you have the correct conversion
coefficient which is that color
underscore RGB to HLS to those outputs
in a hue light saturation image which
looks a little different but it's really
the same thing it's just a different
representation of that same image so
from here we can isolate each layer of
that image so there's the red layer the
green layer the blue layer if we look at
those individually using this notation
where we're looking at all the rows all
the columns of the image and just that
first value in each of those RGB triples
and then plot all those you can start to
see that that yellow left lane line is
showing up in the red and the green
Channel but not the blue channel if we
go back to that Venn diagram of how
colors work red and green the
combination of those two produces
yellows so those are going to be good
indicators for a yellow lane line so if
we do this for all of the hosts of
different color spaces in that warped
perspective and start to see that some
of these look like they might help us to
find those lane lines like those bottom
two are just producing a white value
where that left lane line is some of
them aren't going to be so useful like
those Q channels in the upper left and
then here's just another example of a
different image that's a little bit
harder so if we just pull out the best
those and take a look at them it looks
like some of these might be pretty
useful here the saturation channel in
the upper right looks pretty good it's
isolating those white lane lines even
though the original image is kind of a
white roadway typically we're like a
bridges in the US but in this in this
image because there's a shadow across
the road that saturation channel doesn't
look quite as good so there's going to
be some trade-off here between which
channels we use and how we use them but
getting into edge detection OpenCV has a
couple functions that will detect edges
for us and all this Sobel operators
really doing is taking the derivative of
one of those color channels so if we
pass in that red channel if we have like
a red meeting white it's going to detect
a line where that where those two meet
it's just going to detect the derivative
across that line so the value of that
derivative is what this this plot is so
it does it in the X direction and then
the y direction and then you can
calculate the magnitude just as the sum
of those two squares and this bridge
would be pretty useful on occasions
where our color detection system might
not work so well so it's a good
substitute and then there's another one
called canny edge detection which just
uses that same Sobel system but applies
a couple nice little tricks that throws
out pixels that aren't part of the edge
and then also thresholds the image to
try to connect edges that weren't
connected before so we're going to use
both of these to produce our final guess
at where the lane lines are to do that
we look at this binary threshold inquiry
the red Channel
saying there's a white pixel a high
value for the red channel it looks like
there's a lane line there so if we just
apply a threshold to this red channel
image and write the output of that fresh
holding to a new image we're going to
get an image where everything is black
except the lane lines
so here the threshold is between 200 and
255 which indicates wider on that
grayscale image but we can adjust these
thresholds to try to capture more or
less of the of the lane lines and then
once we do that to all the color
channels and then add in the edge
detection as just a series like a linear
addition so anywhere that there's a
white pixel on one of these binary
threshold ajiz we just add it to it the
final image so then we go we do our red
channel this is just two but you could
have n number of channels here we do it
for the red we add the Sobel edge
detection and then we output this final
binary which is our guess it where those
lane line pixels are I built this kind
of interesting maybe somewhat
interesting little slider thing here to
show you that you can tune these
thresholds and try to add more or less
content so if you flip these little
knobs eventually you'll just guess like
the whole image is aligned see like it's
a it's upset because there's too much so
yeah like these look pretty good
where's the food guy so yeah there the s
moved and we got a little bit more of
that left lane line so you you can mess
around with these thresholds enough
where you you're capturing just the lane
lines and none of the surrounding image
but it's a bit of a trade off some
images they look better than others and
some of the thresholds you need to tune
them like two for that shadow image you
need to tune them for that image but in
other images they'd be a little bit
better if if you dialed back those
thresholds a little bit but now that we
have this binary image we can just run a
some little algorithm to find the left
and the right lines and then we can
apply a curve fit to those lines so
method one is can be applied on any
image and method two here it needs a
previous fit but it runs quite a bit
faster so we try to use method two or
possible but if we don't find a fit we
kind of fall back to this first method
which is little slower but a little more
robust so for method one we take a
histogram of the bottom half of the
image and wherever that histogram Peaks
that's where we think that the line
starts so the y-value here is just the
sum of the pixels at that X location and
the two maximums are where those lines
start this is a good indicator of how
close it can be between a false value
and a real value so here the the lane
that's to the right of ours we're
detecting that line two so throwing out
some of these extraneous points would be
probably pretty useful for this
algorithm but anyway we have our to our
left start and our right start so we're
going to draw a box around those
starting points and any of those white
pixels from the binary image that fall
in that box
we'll just put them in a big list of x
and y values and then for the next one
we'll just add a box on top of that and
do the same thing and as we move up the
line we'll move the boxes based on the
average of the previous line so if the
average starts moving to the left we'll
know that the box the next box needs to
go to the left that's that's how these
boxes start following that line so at
the end of this we have a big list of
all of the Y values and all the x values
of the pixels that were in that line and
you just run a numpy poly fit
second-order polyfit to those pixels and
that gives us the curve fit in pixel
space you can measure the dislike the
pixel two meter conversion by knowing
that in the United States the lanes are
I think they're like three meters wide
12 feet I don't I don't know what that
is in meters but to just do that
conversion and then for the y direction
you know that there each of these dashed
lines is 10 feet long on the right and
there's a set gap so the federal
government likes to control all this on
the highways so it gives us a good
conversion so we can go from pixel
measurements to meter measurements so
we're looking at method two it just
relies on a previous fit we take that
previous fit and move it to the left and
the right by a hundred pixels and that
creates this green boundary and any
pixels that lie in that green boundary
we throw those in a list and then run
that same poly fit system and that
produces these yellow lines which they
seem to look pretty good so the final
piece is creating that that nice image
we had a little bit of text on there one
of them was a radius of curvature so
going to help the car to guess how how
tight the turn needs to be how much
steering wheel he needs to put in he or
she it what our computers so this is you
know there's a little bit of calculus
here we don't need to get into that but
this just uses those fit those fits that
we found previously and then calculates
the radius of curvature also useful is
the distance to the center of the lane
so if the car starts veering to the left
if we keep track of that you can just
have like a simple controller so that
the car will add a little bit of right
steering wheel angle to bring it back to
the center of the lane and it's fairly
straightforward to get this value if you
know where the X locations of the right
and the left lane are and you assume
that the cameras on the centerline of
the car then the centerline of the car
is at the center of the image so that's
that's how I got those values obviously
if it's not mounted on the center then
there just need to be some offset here
so getting that that nice green picture
you just take the two curve fits you
found plot those on the on the image
using this polylines function and then
fill in the space between those lines
with the the green fill which is that
first function the fill poly but this is
in Warped space so this is from that
bird's eye view which we can't really
overlay on that final image it'll kind
of look a little goofy but it's pretty
easy to go from that warped image to the
original image if you just swap those
source and destination points we talked
about so you swap those apply the same
function that under store phone and
it'll output that nice overlay if you
just use this ad weighted function which
adds a transparently weighted layer to
that image
so finally you can just throw some text
on there with this put text function and
that's that's how we got that nice
picture and then to run this on a series
of images I just used a couple a couple
tools for that but it basically applied
this same pipeline to all the images in
a video and saves it at the end of the
day so that's that's how I did that but
working on how do we make this a little
bit more robust this doesn't work super
well on off highway driving so when the
corners are really tight sometimes the
curve fits kind of wander around or if
there's a car passing you that car can
throw off our like where we can't see
the line anymore so a couple ideas for
how to make it a little bit better the
image warping is assumed to be constant
across all the images all the images so
we just use those same source and
destination points but in reality as the
car moves like to the left in the lane
the start of the lines start to move so
we get a little bit of distortion when
we go to that bird's-eye view so having
a dynamic system where it picks out the
start of the lines then uses those for
the image warping would be useful also
being able to dynamically control those
thresholds based on how much signal is
in that image so if there's something
that's creating a lot of white in our
binary threshold image being able to
tune those thresholds so that we scale
back the content of that image also the
speed this obviously needs to happen in
real time on a self-driving car but it
took me about three and a half minutes
to process that video which was I don't
know maybe 20 seconds long so obviously
we need to speed this one up
the smoothing system I use I just keep
track of the last five previous fits and
do an average of those fits and that's
kind of my best prediction of the the
current line but if there's some times
in the United States
they'll divert the lanes around some
construction so as those lanes shift in
[Music]
encourage really fast the system's going
to be slow to respond to that so you
know having just a weighted average
where you wait the most recent line fit
the highest would be useful here or
maybe some exponential smoothing but
other than that that's the little system
that I built so are there any there any
questions also the the that ipython
notebooks available on this get in this
github repo so if you want to play
around with it yourself I should
probably put some install instructions
because you need like open CV and a
bunch of other tools but um if you go
back to the walking the first step yeah
you need to find the full edge points I
didn't quite understand how you find
these four can you say something about
that lady's computer so the question
well I think everybody heard that image
warping yeah this one so this is really
just guess and test so I fiddled with
these points until I used a straight a
straight piece of road so I knew that
the final warped image was going to have
straight lines and I just fiddled with
the points until I got them to be
straight and then the amount of like the
height of that image is based on the
y-value of those
points so if you move them further out
you'll get more perspective I could have
look further out on the road but
obviously there's a little bit less
signal out there so this is where like
dynamically choosing these points would
be useful because they're not always in
the same position Thanks yep so you seem
to rely a lot on the kind of empty roads
that one on littering is using car
commercials and this wouldn't really be
realistic for the kind of heavily
trafficked roads that we have in cities
because cars common on the structure
view of the lanes I was wondering if
there's any attempts to turn that noise
into an actual extra information right
so yeah this is basically a system
that's only going to work in the United
States on highways but it turns out that
that's probably some of the most useful
and easiest to solve problems in the
self-driving car space but yeah I mean
just driving around Germany here this
system would break down really quickly
there's sometimes there's no left lane
it seems like in the United States
there's a little bit more regulation as
to you know there's always a double
yellow which indicates I can't cross the
middle and there's always a right lane
line so you definitely need different
models for different countries and then
the in city driving would would
definitely be a challenge I live in New
York and you know it's just it's mayhem
out there so this would this would
definitely not work in the city but yeah
the techniques that they use to solve
the city piece are really interesting
maybe next time I'll do I'll do one
about that
did you just how did you test your
algorithm do you have any ground truth
data set or how do you collect your data
to test the algorithm or do you just
look at the pictures manually and say
okay algorithms performs better or less
good than your previous stage of the
algorithm how do you do that yes this is
all pretty manual at the moment I should
note that all this all this data comes
from Udacity has an open source
self-driving car system they're trying
to build so they've got a couple hundred
gigabytes of video and images that
anybody can play around with via all the
testing it was pretty manual you know
like manually moving those sliders
around and looking at output images but
I was trying to think about that how to
like automate some of those systems I
think that'd be pretty challenging
because you need you need to know what's
a good lane line fit and a computer
doesn't really know that until you show
it so some part of the pipeline is going
to have to be a little bit manual but I
think once you have this system figured
out you could train your model on you
know the output of the system and kind
of create your own training data
so a quick question you were using
projections of your environment so my
naive idea would have been you know to
build a three-dimensional model to do
this kind of task is it common to use
projections or is it even possible to do
3d modeling in real time yeah so I I
don't think they use cameras to do 3d
modeling because they have that lidar
system so the lidar is gonna if I shine
lidar like it's just a beam of laser
light if I shine that around this room
it's going to give me a 3d a set of 3d
points of this room so that's
continually running on the car so they
they overlay that with like Google has
all of their map data and that's one way
that they localize have you have a set
of like two cameras you can create a
pretty it's a pretty rough 3d image but
that is possible but with one camera
it's a little bit more challenging as
you can see like you lose a decent
amount of image fidelity as you start
like warping around so yeah it'd be a
little bit challenging I think but it's
a neat idea
i-i can't formulate this in several ways
but let's put it let's put it like this
we're thinking in some future tensorflow
will replace OpenCV in doing this and if
if deep learning will take over this
field how would you see the next steps
orb yeah yeah I think that's that kind
of gets back to the previous a previous
question for sure running a series of
these images through some deep learning
network could give you some idea of like
where these edges are it's going to
start to develop a model that way but I
think I think the training data is going
to have to be some manual process of
like picking out here is the lane or or
whatever so this you know maybe you
could use this to generate your training
data and then to run it on you know
billions of images versus just a couple
hundred by hand so yeah I think for sure
like the future is going to be more in
that direction rather than this
pipelines really slow so it'd be hard to
run in real time yeah thank you for the
presentation so the way I understood it
do processing each image separately and
then you apply the smoothing after the
techride but given the way the data is
structured wouldn't be a natural way to
use the last few predictions or the last
few well data points to include them in
the prediction for the next data point
so kind of you have very strong prior of
where you're there lanes are from the
previous image because you're taking
picture every 50 milliseconds or so
right right
so with this would make it much more
robust maybe to compare to processing
each image separately yeah I so I didn't
really want to talk about like classes
and annoying Python things but yeah so I
have like a lame class where I keep
track of
previous fits at any given point in time
so I use that and then we you so you
know like kind of where the line should
be and then you just guess in that area
and then if you don't find it that's
when you fall back on kind of the the
more computationally intense process but
via the smoothing is happening like in
real time like in that space or that
image VF for sure I should be like
waiting that for that latest fit a
little bit more than the previous four
or whatever
when detecting lanes and a camera image
you always have the problems with
shadows and lightening conditions have
you ever thought of using Lane detection
or using multiple sources of sensors
like you have mounted on your car
for example leader Sanders yeah so like
when there's rain or snow on the camera
lens it's gonna be really hard to detect
them so this is just one system that
these companies use to really this is
all about finding exactly where I am on
the roadway so GPS is a sensor that they
use but that's only accurate to 10 feet
so you use that to kind of get you in
the ballpark you can use this to know
where I am in the roadway but also that
that lidar system because Google has
such good Maps they just overlay the
lidar data with the map data and that's
that's pretty good for saying you're
here plus or minus a few inches and then
there's a there's a number of other
sensors they can use but so this is kind
of just one piece of the localization
function as a whole of finding where you
are in the world yeah thanks guys